Bruce You can't keep doing this
Step out of the shadows
and let tombstones be your families legacy
I know your trying to create a myth
Just remember
Theres room for bruce and batman inside that suit
Too long
this city has burned
with corruption and greed
and with bruces help
A vote for Harby Dent
Is a vote to finally put your foot down
Vicky Vale
Reporter for the Gotham
Is the Dent campaign
facilitating votes for Gothams biggest crime family
Money gets money
or I can pull it out from under him
Your men despised men like
I haven't tried yet
Come on
A fire is heading this way
You must show the world the true nature of a wade
I think this whole cities a crime scene
A revolution is knocking on Gothams door
When this whole thing starts, make sure your on the right side
Well then
time to save the city
Hey youtubers its Charlie so
Happy comic con week new batman telltale trailer
the games dropping like two weeks after comiccon
so lets break it down
if you guys didn't know telltale games
just like if they make a walking dead narrative game
inside the batman universe
and as you see harvey dent here
that has two both very pretty looking sides of his face
you might guess that it has something to do with the long halloween story line
that was the story line where he was going after the mob
carmine falcone
while he was seating in the witness stand
threw acid in his face
all the different movies took a slightly different take on this
in the most recent
Aron Acavs  version of the character was a pretty good..
representation he was like
a guy that could be batman
but takes a turn for the worst
and becomes a supervillian instead
like gothams white knight
thats the way he was portrayed in christopher nolans dark knight trilogy
He's a friend of Bruces so it was very personal for him
that one of his friends has turned into a supervillan
you see catwomen show up in the trailer
so as it is with the other games like game of thrones
telltale, walking dead telltale
if you haven't played a telltale game
theres different episodes which just expands the stories
So the first episode will drop this august
that will be about x amount of story
The next episode will be released a couple of months after that
They'll continue the story line
Game of thrones was about 6 episodes
I think this is scheduled for at least 5 episodes
It might be more than that but I'm only saying five
So you buy the game for like 20, 25 odd bucks
and you get the other installments for free
most of you have probably played some version of a telltale game
So you know the drill, its like a 25 dollar game
It is very cutscene heavy
So usually I buy the steam version
but you can buy it on consoles
Its not like playing a triple A game that s like 60 gigs on your hard drive
most of the gameplay is relatively easy once you get the hang of the controls
The way I think about it is a mixture between a movie, a game and a interactive comic book
but in like the next 10-15 years we're going to see interactive comic books anyway
especially because of the virtual reality batman game that they're working on
this is not that, its a totally different thing
there is a virtual reality batman game
that you'll be able to play with your oculus or your HTCV
or whatever gear that you have
but for the most part this two face storyline
seems like its going to be out of the long halloween
like a lot of the things you've been seeing recently with the batman mythos
and if you haven't been reading batman rebirth
like the comic books that are happening right now
Bruce Waynes kinda mellowed out
his working with batwoman
Who might show up in the DC TV Shows
supergirl in particular
but you don't need to read the comics to understand whats going on here
the look they're going with for the game y'know the art style
Is very Jim Lee, Greg Capulo, Neil Adams
If you don't know the difference they're the biggest batman artists of all time
Neil Adams very Identifiable
as old school, 70s, 80s batman
Jim Lee  little bit more recently
Greg Capulo is the latest guy to do batman
So if you've been reading any type of batman comic in the last 10 years
The artwork will look very famillar
and for those of you asking what platform this will be dropping on
It will pretty much drop on every single platform
so no worries about that
You can see episode 1 out for digital download on August 2nd
Thats the week suicide squad comes out
what an amazing coincidence
so it should be a lot of fun
Its relatively cheap compared to most triple A games
like its not a triple A game
So check it out it should be a lot of fun
If you really want a deep cut from the comics like and you want like a Harvey Dent Story
just re read the long Halloween
one of the best batman stories of all time
If you guys didn't know in related comic con news
Theres going to be a whole bunch of DC Comic Con stuff this week
because its comic con comes with a territory
There is a DC giveaway that Im doing thats going on right now
all you have to do is enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video
I was originally going to do some Flash Season 3 today
But then all these trailers drop so Im just going to do that next
then I'll do a comiccon schedule which will explain whats going on and what day its going to drop
the videos I'll be doing for it like all the important stuff
so look out for that I will be doing batman gameplay videos
on my video game channel
theres links for my video game channel and my bonus channel down in the description. so just
check the description its all down tehre
So while you guys wait for my next video to post
You can click here for all my comic con previews
you can click here to learn whats going on with the flash season 3 and the new black flash
So thanks for watching lets high five and I'll see you guys tonight
*music plays*